hey 42 here from the medieval Knights of
Europe in full plate armor to the silent
ninja assassins of Japan which warrior
culture from history were the fastest
deadliest and most adept at killing who
will take the crown let's find out first
up is the ancient Mexican civilization
of the Aztecs war was such an integral
part of Aztec culture but when a new
Aztec leader was elected it was expected
of him to immediately wage a military
campaign against an enemy tribe to prove
his worth
when else Tech's attacked an enemy they
had two goals firstly to take their land
and make it theirs and secondly to take
prisoners so they could sacrifice them
to the gods
making the Aztec warriors a force to be
feared because unlike most fighting
forces that would give you a clean death
the Aztecs were a lot more brutish when
it came to disposing of their enemies
prisoners of war would often be
strangled or stoned to death during
religious ceremonies they were masters
of fear and intimidation in fact they
designed a special musical instrument
that had the sole purpose of
intimidating the enemy before a battle
it was called the Aztec death whistle
and it was in the shape of a skull it
produced a truly horrific sound this is
the noise it made when you blew into it
now that's just one whistle now imagine
a thousand Aztec warriors charging
towards you whilst blowing on a thousand
deaf whistles in a bone-chilling
Symphony I don't know about you but I'd
be off the Mongols were an Asian army
led by the revered Genghis Khan they
were focused on one goal destruction
they destroyed and conquered everything
in their paths they took no prisoners
and were widely considered as a bunch of
barbarians and savages their combat
skills however have been matched by few
throughout history they fought on
horseback and were masters of the bow
and arrow they specialized in shooting
their arrows whilst riding their horses
at high speeds and they were bloody good
at it they used a variety of bows and
arrows such as a combi simpler which
specialized in ripping through armor
they also used their so-called howling
arose that would emit a terrifying sound
whilst flying through the air this sound
would disorientate the enemy and cause
panic their fearsome fighting power
salive Genghis Khan and his Mongol army
to conquer more of the world than any
other Empire in history
the Maori are the indigenous people of
New Zealand they were well known for
eating their conquered foes because they
believed they would gain their mana mana
was at the core of the Mara's beliefs
mana was believed to be spiritual power
and prestige the Maori would intimidate
their enemies by performing a special
dance before a fight called a haka puru
puru
the same dance is still performed today
by New Zealand's official rugby team the
All Blacks before every game to
intimidate their opponents next up are
the masters of stealth the silent
assassins known as ninjas they started
out as humble farmers but unsatisfied
with the way that they were being
treated by the samurai military they
trained rigorously in the shadows to
become silent deadly killers and rose up
against the samurai but being poor
farmers they couldn't defeat the samurai
in open combats because unlike the
samurai they had no armor so they
devised ways to be unseen and kill the
samurai when they least expected it in
the most underhanded and devious ways
they were known for their superior
ability to kill and then disappear in
seconds only weapons was illegal in
Japan for anyone except the samurai
military so ninjas had to fashion their
weapons out of simple farming tools such
as the sickle which they turned into the
deadly cursory gamma they also used a
short sword called a ninja toe similar
to a katana but shorter the ninjetta was
lightweight and fast they also had an
arsenal of long range weapons such as
the poisonous blowgun the deadly
shuriken or ninja star as well as black
eggs which were egg shells painted black
and then filled with ground-up shards of
glass their purpose was to blind and
disorientate the enemy ninjas would
throw them into their opponents faces
blinding them and causing agonizing pain
next up is the Persian immortal they
served as the Imperial Guard for the
Persian Empire the Immortals were a
group of heavy
inventory that stood 10,000 strong they
got their name because they never seemed
to die every time an immortal died fell
ill was injured or died in battle they
were instantly replaced by another
reserved immortal so there was always
exactly ten thousand also if an immortal
died during combat their body will be
immediately pulled from the battlefield
by the other immortals and replaced by a
new immortal from the reserves this was
done to maintain the impression that
they were unkillable hence the name they
fought with shields and Spears and also
used a bow and arrow from afar they
weren't particularly skilled with the
bow but it did it matter because they
would overwhelm their enemies by firing
thousands of arrows all in unison
leaving the enemy with nowhere to hide
next up is the very foundation of the
Roman army the Roman legion they were
the infantry that helped to conquer and
create the most powerful Empire in the
history of the world the Roman Empire
the Roman Empire was large and wealthy
and the Roman legion therefore had the
best armor swords shields and Spears
that money could buy they went to the
effort of covering themselves in all
that nice armor and then they wore
sandals seriously
but sandals aside they were masters of
the shield and spear combination but
what made the Roman legion and
subsequently the Roman Empire so
successful was the fact that they were
constantly adapting as soon as they
found fighting practices and techniques
that were better than their own they
would instantly abandon their old ways
in favor of the new techniques this
enabled them to always stay ahead of
their enemies and hold a Roman Empire
for over 500 years in training they
would focus on mastering the thrust of
the sword or spear instead of the slash
the frost was far more lethal when
facing armored opponents and meant the
Roman legion had higher kill rates in
their enemies during battles next up is
a fearless band of warriors bound by
honor and Jews II of course I'm talking
about the samurai they mastered the
sharpest sword that has
being forged the legendary the deadly
katana the katana could easily slice a
man in half in the right hands samurai
were highly trained and incredibly
disciplined killing machines they led
their lives by the code of Bushido
meaning the way of the warrior but by
far what made the samurai so
unbelievably deadly was that they
weren't afraid to give their lives for
their masters they were trained to
believe that before all things a samurai
should constantly keep in the forefront
of his mind
a simple inevitable truth that they had
to die and if they didn't achieve their
goals or their masters goals before
dying it was considered cowardly because
of these beliefs if a summer I failed in
battle they would commit ritual suicide
often voluntarily but sometimes is a
punishment from their masters this
ritual suicide was known as seppuku and
involves the samurais stabbing himself
in the stomach with a short sword then
dragging the blade to the left or right
to slice open his abdomen and disembowel
himself that's pretty darn gruesome and
it meant only those with the strongest
mind would become samurai warriors this
absence of fear of death made the
samurai the most fearless warriors that
ever lived
next up the most feared fighting force
in Europe between the 8th and 11th
centuries the Vikings barbaric in nature
their attacks were fast and brutal they
effortlessly mowed down everyone who
dared get in their way
they raided and pillaged across almost
all of Europe often grabbing what riches
they caught before returning to their
homeland of Scandinavia the battle ax
was the weapon of choice for these
Nordic groups who were often large in
size making them easily able to
overpower their skinny little
southwestern European counterparts
however the rumors that they had horns
on their helmets and they drank out of
the skulls of their enemies are complete
myth they were actually gentle giants
no just kidding they were violent
savages even their religion was centered
around war and they believe that when a
Viking died they would go to Valhalla
where they would prepare for
an enormous battle called Ragnarok what
they did do some good for Europe they
were exceptionally good at trading with
the rest of Europe so we also have a lot
to thank them for next up is the
medieval night a fully clad
battle-hardened warrior that was a force
to be reckoned with Knights were the
wealthiest and best trained warriors in
the entire medieval world often fighting
on horseback with only the best armor
shields and tempered steel long swords
Knights train their entire lives mainly
because they were idolized and young
boys would often want to become Knights
from an early age they really uphold as
a piece and fought by a strict code of
honor all Knights had to swear by the
Knights code of chivalry which included
lines such as to protect the weak and
defenseless to fight for the welfare of
all and never to refuse a challenge from
an equal that's right Knights were bound
by law to always accept a jewel even if
they happen to be in the middle of
taking a bath or some other equally
uncompromising situation for this reason
they had trusty Squires who would always
be by their side to have their armored
sword and shield handy and lastly are
arguably the most skilled fighters to
ever grace the ancient world the
legendary Spartans Spartans underwent
brutal training their entire lives at
the tender age of 7 Spartan boys were
ripped from their family home and began
the Agoge the state-sponsored training
program the Agoge was utterly relentless
and violent which prepared them for
real-life combat situations or like
almost every of a warrior in history
Spartans had no professions to distract
them from training they were not Smith's
bakers or candlestick makers they were
one thing and one thing only elite
fighting machines trained to kill and
not to be killed when a child was born
in Sparta the mother would instantly
bathe it in wine to ensure it was strong
if the child was weak it would die soon
after later the elders would inspect the
baby if it was found to be deformed in
any way the poor thing was thrown from
the top of a cliff into a chasm this
horrific aliy brutal treatment produced
the greatest Legion of close combat
fighters the world
ever see they specialized in three main
weapons the sphere which could kill a
man several feet away with a single
thrust also the short sword and finally
the most important part of their arsenal
the round Spartan shield which was used
just as much offensively as it was
defensively a Spartan was covered in
bronze from head to toe they were like
tanks tanks that could stab things the
Spartans are best known for their heroic
performance at the Battle of Thermopylae
in 480 BC when just free hundred
Spartans led by King Leonidas of Sparta
fought off a hundred and fifty thousand
Persian soldiers for three days straight
the Spartans eventually lost the fight
but their display of courage resilience
and amazing fighting ability against an
army that so greatly outnumbered their
own has never been matched in all of
history for goodness sake there were 500
Persians for each Spartan and they
lasted three days
that's pretty damn impressive the
Spartans had a powerful saying that
their wise would tell them before
leaving for battle come back with your
shield or on top of it which meant don't
come back unless you are victorious
thanks for the view subscribe for more
you